Simona thanks very much let's bring in
Tala Abdul Raziq he's a researcher at
the University of Exodus strategy and
security Institute he joins us from
London Tala Abdul Raziq what's your
reading of a second day of violence this
is just a perpetuation of the you know
the tit for tat violence that we've seen
over the past several months the pro
Iran militia groups that I'll probably
behind this when I say probably because
you know it's only them that are capable
of moving around so freely in that
region it's just north of Baghdad
it's a highly secure zone and it's very
much controlled by the Yaqui Armed
Forces of which the popular mobilization
forces these Shia militias are a part of
so it's very clear to me kind of who is
behind this and it's not going to stop
until they get their way and in that you
know well they're looking for
essentially is for the Americans to
leave as your correspondent just rightly
said you know they want to make them
feel as unwelcome as possible so they
can decide to withdraw and to back out
the heart of me rock however that's
going to be a tall ask for the United
States because they see Iraq as kind of
a poster child for their you know the
democratic experiment as it were in the
Middle East and that's actually failing
and on top of that they also have a
counterterrorism mission to deal with
Isis the problem being though is that
the jihadists the Sunni jihadists of
Isis are actually being replaced by
these Shia jihadists who are fighting
within the popular mobilization forces
so essentially you have a unit of the
Iraqi army firing missile barrages at a
fellow unit of the Iraqi army as we
heard to Iraqi Air Force personnel were
seriously injured as well as attacking
an allied force which is the us-led
coalition against Isis so it's a very
complicated state of affairs right now
and it's only probably going to get
worse and escalate even further but what
are the chances that they get what they
want
I US forces withdrawal because in the
run-up to the death of customs sulemani
what two months ago now I guess eight
nine ten weeks maybe
US President Donald Trump signaling I
want out of the region Qasem Soleimani
is assassinated and then the US the
State
the Pentagon has they are actually yes
okay we're gonna stay in I think right
now the chances are slim and I don't
think any concrete decisions are going
to be made until after the u.s.
presidential election this year no one
wants to kind of do any kind of major
policy shakeups right now least of all
Donald Trump he wants to feel secure in
office first before he makes any rash
decisions as it were I also don't think
that they will take the ultimate
decision to leave Iraq so soon because
it would look like but they are
acquiescing to pressure from the
Iranians and that will obviously harm us
prestige at the end of the day the
entire point of the maximum pressure
campaign against the Iranians is to
enforce an American point of view that
the Iranians shouldn't be able to
develop ballistic missiles they
shouldn't further their nuclear weapons
program if they have one and they should
not be interfering in the internal
affairs of American allies such as Saudi
Arabia the UAE and others so I don't
think the Americans are simply going to
just pack up and leave it's not in their
interests and it's not in the interests
of their allies and they they earn
billions of dollars in arms purchases
and defense contracts from these allies
so as I said I don't think it's likely
to happen anytime soon
tella Abdul Raziq we have to leave it
there thank you very much